(ripping effect)
- Lorraine says hi.
And Lorraine from South
Carolina: "I'm stuck.
"I'm hoping that you
can help me get unstuck.
"My career, my living
arrangements all need an overhaul,
"I'm so overwhelmed right now.
"How do I start?
"Thank you," Lorraine.
- Hey Lorraine. I think
when you feel overwhelmed,
you feel stuck.
I think you kind of of,
in this moment Lorraine,
it's really probably a call
just to create a bit
of a reflective space.
And come back to think
of, what is your big idea
going to solve?
And who is the audience?
And what is their pain point?
And how can you help them
overcome that pain point?
And a beauty about this,
particularly when you become
overwhelmed and you've got
to-do list kind of this long,
is cut back to the essence of your idea,
your product, your service.
And why it's going to change the world?
And then the other thing,
you know, the magic of simplification.
You know, what does it
do that you can actually,
in a consumer product, make
the consumer's life better?
Or a B-2-B sort of world,
really try to take hostile,
or improve their top line,
or take hassle out of their organization
and less stress.
So I think you just got
to come back to basics.
Just focus on where's your audience,
what idea is going to kind
of really change the world
and create a market for
your product or service.
And then if you do that,
you can get really clear
about what's important.
And actually one other thing.
I hope I'm kind of not doing
motherhood and apple pie here.
But loads of people get into
you know, this is urgent, this
is urgent, this is urgent,
and their, kind of, to-do
list grows and grows
and becomes overwhelming
and your head's spinning.
I'd ask yourself if you got a mission,
what's really important?
'Cause everything, everything
could appear urgent,
but there's very few things
that are really important.
And what's going to really move the dial?
And then just focus your
urges about moving the dial
and actually Lorraine,
what you can do mentally
is create a bucket in the corner,
and if there's lots of good ideas,
and they're not fundamentally important,
just right 'em down,
chuck it in the bucket.
Come back to 'em in 90 day's time.
But really focus on what's important.
And, you know, I'd say where
you get confidence from
is not only the idea
and then the strategy,
but where you get success
from is awesome execution.
Really executing the hell out of an idea.
- I agree with you.
I echo a lot of what you said.
I think you've got to just simplify.
I would look at what is the one thing
that if I focused on,
that would really have a big impact
and have a ripple effect.
'Cause once you start making
progress on one thing,
and you're getting getting some results,
it bleeds into everything
else you're doing.
Once you're confident,
you're more confident
in a business deal,
you become more confident in
your personal life, as well.
It bleeds through everything.
And so I'd be looking at,
okay, there's a thousand
things that you have to do,
what's the one single most important thing
that if you fix this,
it will not only help
that once situation but
everything around it as well.
And then focus on doing that
and eliminate the distractions around it.
(ripping sound effect)